it was a lavish White House ceremony
crowded with cabinet members lawmakers
and executives from large US
corporations President Trump held the
deal as remarkable today we take a
momentous step one that has never been
taken before with China toward a future
of fair and reciprocal trade as we sign
phase 1 of the historic trade deal
between the United States and China
together we are writing the wrongs of
the past and delivering a future of
economic justice and security for
American workers farmers and families
sentiments echoed by China's signatory
to the deal come around war for dodgers
Vava China and the United States with
the larger picture in mind have taken a
serious approach to our differences and
work to manage them appropriately
reaching the Phase one trade agreement
it is good for China for the United
States in the world the reality though
that this is just an initial deal and
many problematic issues in the us-china
relationship remain unaddressed I think
that it has moved the needle a little
bit with with China and it has made some
progress but at the same time I don't
think that it achieves the fundamental
structural changes that are going to
need to happen for us the u.s. tech
sector in particular to really feel
comfortable president Trump's political
opponents insist he's been outsmarted by
his Chinese counterpart I greatly fear
that President Xi is laughing at us
behind our backs for having given away
so little at the expense of American
workers farmers and businesses the
administration in order to get a deal at
all costs before the 2020 election has
thrown the American worker and American
business overboard and they're going to
be the ones left to face the
consequences omits the smiles and
celebrations the awareness that this is
not an end to the trade war it is at
this stage merely
a truce
my canna al-jazeera Washington analysis
now from Dan Wang who is an analyst at
the Economist Intelligence Unit and she
believes China has given up more than
the u.s. in this new trade deal this
looks to me a very big concession on
China's side and I genuinely don't see
how China can fulfill its commitment of
200 billion more dollars a purchase from
the US with without increasing its
fiscal subsidies to domestic producers
manufacturers dramatically and if China
along the way of this two years actually
cannot fulfill some of the commitment
and then we're expecting to see a
collapse of the phase one deal and that
means the phase two and phase three
would never happen it looks like a for
example the agricultural deal in this
phase one deal it is more than twice the
amount of the 2017 level and in order to
do that actually a lot of a domestic
producers farmers will suffer a lot
China would certainly increase its
government purchase prices and expand
that program but overall that means
direct competition with Chinese domestic
farmers start a mostly small scale and
in that area China is not competitive
and another thing that's funny to me is
that by signing this deal actually China
has to commit to buy more agricultural
goods from the US and that means buy a
lot less from other countries for
example Canada and you and by signing
this deal in fact between China and the
US it is China it is the US allies
fundamentally berry most of the cost in
the end
[Music]